Hausa go right right welcome to outlast
I'm so pumped to play this it's gonna be
awesome this is one of the most
anticipated Oregon's this year and
there's a lot of great horror games
coming out this year so I'm really happy
to have it I'm really happy to play it
for you bros it's gonna be a good time
put on your new pants actually it's
probably better if you don't wear any
pants not I think about it you know what
watch this all sitting on the toilet you
already are the lights is nasty I expect
nothing less of your breath there's a
little warning isn't it sexual content
that's the first thing I read okay
you're miles ups that up that ups up you
are miles Upshur an investigative
investigative reporter whose ambition is
about to earn him an intimate tour of
hell and unearth always willing to risk
digging into the stories no other
journalists would dare investigate you
will seek out the dark secret at the
heart of Mount massive Asselin mount
massive ask sorry
stay alive as long as you can record
everything you are not a fighter the
horizontal mounting a mean-ass method
and explore the truth your only choices
are to run hide and die or die okay we
knew this if you watch the demo or
whatever oh [ __ ]
and oh that is also part
I was missing two bread Nick come on am
i driving anyway seems the aerofoil park
now that is [ __ ] creepy
I hope I hope that I don't know about
the character man like Reagan who would
do this [ __ ] I hope it's just done not
an idiot I hope there's some meeting
Biden all BAM
okay well I guess this is our stuff huh
oh okay confidential grab that [ __ ]
miles farad jameelah huh you don't know
me have to make this quick they might be
monitoring I did two weeks of software
console of Murkoff psychiatrist systems
facilities in Mount massive all sorts of
NBA's and I'm very breaking right now
but seriously [ __ ] those guys terrible
things happening here don't understand
it don't believe half of the things I
saw doctors talking about dream therapy
going too deep finding something that
had been waiting for them in a mountain
people are being hurt on Merck I was
making money in this big
the graphics are really good like this
is coming out on the PlayStation 4 and
having this whoa it's something creepy
gonna happen I don't like this Oh what
are you doing
we get it you have a camera jeez
oh hell no new objective instigate
amount massive ass okay I what we should
control of the games you're not even
watching me Here I am baby I don't think
there's anything to do here
well this gates better open hi
so I guess this is kind of where the
packs demo started I don't know if I
should should play it again or just edit
in okay I'm gonna play it if you want to
watch it I'll just leave a link isiliye
this doesn't look different
what the hell hello that [ __ ] yeah
that's not gonna work
are those military trucks okay it looks
like we're gonna find it someone knock
on the door Shh I have this strange
feeling of being watched
oh this is way too big an yep oh well oh
well the shame for me I already play
with oh I don't want to play again I
still would oh [ __ ]
I have a guy the thing is business I
know what's gonna happen more or less
but it's still gonna scare me I know it
that's how scary this game is see I
didn't even remember that [ __ ]
I hope this game is really long I hope
it's more than 10 hours I doubt it
but still I'll be happy coz from what I
saw oh [ __ ] there's some batteries
oh they upgraded the animation that's
cool I remember there was nothing here
now there's a note though
um I'm not gonna read all the notes I'll
open them oh [ __ ]
that did not happen last time hello I
really need to take a [ __ ] this game is
a true nightmare oh well let's go here
huh is that a you pickle cord I ate
those for breakfast okay diam they seem
to have toned down a little bit to bring
more attention or whatever which would
make sense
Wow who the [ __ ] is that guy
no bad game don't [ __ ] with me oh no no
no no no no hey hey hey I'm new here I'm
the new guy I get it let's pick on the
new guy oh [ __ ] I forgot about you oh
god damn it why am i reading notes night
mission
where's your where's your way back
where's your headache why this noise
it's just a regular party you're alive I
remember you know yeah there you go
hey girl tell me everything it killed us
you caught out the very uh-huh you can't
fight them you have to hi hi unlock the
base doors
I took comfort like oh I better get out
of here okay I remember that little
[ __ ] let's check in here can I take a
[ __ ] oh thank god oh Jesus Christ what
is that that is a hey I fine hey that is
adorable
why would you bring can I use this whoa
oh my god free bacon well now it's not
the chance for bacon am I kidding
there's all this chat I mean okay
okay I mean there's no thing little fake
that is quite the welcoming and who are
you my name is massive ass
I mean wait that's you wait what
now I'm confused why I don't look at my
born merciful God you have sent me an
apostle go ahead your lives it's not
that great point love coffee
I'm hoping now that I will wake up here
because last time we woke up somewhere
else yes
okay this is new for me yes oh I mean no
I mean I'm happy and not happy at the
same time hey there
nice pants I hear red is really in this
year what it says confidential not
anymore you're not
I'm inside that's what nothing but is
everywhere blood burn marks head light
up with bottles behind a bar dead Mugler
scientists hung from the ceiling their
badges Samer love I mean more like
advanced research system merlocks a long
time am i messing in on all a tactical
cop pinned like a pig on a spit the hell
is I mean all right I like I don't be so
creepy okay so this place is called
merlok and this game has weird names all
right there's a new sheriff in town
where's your head at
what is right David Oh JA bloody head
the vector plant you scared the [ __ ] out
of me
sharp is this far to say hi Jesus Christ
don't ever do that [ __ ] again okay we
better look for more batteries okay well
it looks like there's nothing in here
what was that all right it's looks well
lit a nice hello everyone hi hi you
don't a lot of [ __ ] computers what is
this my craft did I do that
mmm no way oh my god that's awesome
I can draw dicks out of blood if I
wanted to
Oh exit yes Oh course hello hi hi hi
there huh did he move what hi excuse me
sorry I'm an investigative reporter just
don't wanna don't wanna [ __ ] anyone how
you would would you like some some
toilet paper I know the toilets are [ __ ]
I know
okay well I'm just gonna walk past pass
you as hey how you doin like you're on
YouTube [ __ ] oh okay
well laugh
you have great eyebrows see they glow in
the dark and [ __ ] um you could be an
Alan I'm sure I'm sure
I don't okay well good good good to hang
it out with you oh that's my favorite
show too cray okay that's good
don't need to [ __ ] with anyone hello not
a big fan of [ __ ] okay as a Badge
fine you didn't jumpy that's great so we
got a key card and then your objective
escape
well that's [ __ ] ain't happening let's
be honest okay so now we can go here and
that's sure if I want to go go there
anyway
guys don't watch porn Jesus Christ
hi your [ __ ] let's go away
let go man shut up I don't give a [ __ ]
oh that's right you don't [ __ ] with me
yeah yeah I was gonna give you toilet
paper I thought we were cool ah jeez
what a dick uncool man
hey I'm back in the black
once everyone missing a head what does
it say
proclaim the gospel not on my watch
[ __ ] oh okay there's a lot of places
to come how about down here actually how
about not note that you can look behind
you by holding Q and E while running no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
what the [ __ ] is oh [ __ ]
that's awesome and nothing I want to do
listen
that's [ __ ] genius that is [ __ ]
genius are you ready for this sing it
for me brows dan dan dan dan dan dan dan
dan dan dan under y'all oh I didn't
worry what is going on here confidential
not anymore
gonna post all that [ __ ] on YouTube what
about in here why should we have to pay
for it good why we have to die walking
will kill us just for being big who
still people huh yeah yeah yeah G that's
what the oh hey hi hi oh I should close
this they lie walls never lied geez
you
doing great for us hi you were a little
scaler that before whoa whoa what is he
doing
no how stay
scheisse oh honey the locker by your
legs yeah yeah pick hey I know but I
mean Oh fine I did not mean to do that
[ __ ]
oh that cliffhanger ending I'm sorry for
us but I really have to end the first
episode here maybe like if you enjoyed
in looking forward to this playthrough I
know it's gonna be amazing if this video
gets 50,000 likes before tonight I'll
upload part two right away is that a
deal I think that's the deal so a lot of
people are saying outlast is the new
amnesia kind of what are you bursting do
you think out less is scarier than a
Michelle do you think I'm usually
scarier than out less from what you've
seen so far I left the pole in the first
link in description that you can go and
vote I think it'll be pretty interesting
to see anyway hit subscribe to come over
today and I'll see you in the next video
stay awesome bros love you
oh if you whoa whoa
whoa
oh [ __ ] go through